disabling the encryption is an executive
order it takes two alpha level members
don't worry company's coming
did you get my flower I'm glad you're
here next really cuz I thought you had
me killed you know how the game works
so what make me hit if she because
you're the best and the most ruthless
person I ever met
I did what I did to protect our enemies
are your enemies name disorder war just
a matter of time before dirty bomb goes
off in Moscow or an EMP Fries Chicago
diplomacy holding action a band-aid and
you know where I learned that Bogota you
didn't ask he just did what had to be
done I can bring order to the lives of 7
billion people by sacrificing 20 million
it's the next step Nick
you have the courage to take it no I
have the courage not
retinal scanner don't think we've wiped
her clearance from the Sun no you erased
my password probably deleted my retinal
scan but if you want to stay ahead of me
mr. secretary
you need to keep both eyes open
alpha level confirm encryption code
accepted
same country
you